dad waited a long time to do a movie
musical and I've wanted certainly to put
myself up there and I actually had a
meeting with Tom before it even signed
on to this I said I want to audition
he's like whoa whoa fella settle down
approaching this was I wanted to do it
live all the way through and from the
very beginning I did have an idea of
what I wanted to do like you chart a
performance I kind of looked at within
the song to kind of figure out what's
going on and try to take this amazing
iconic piece of music and translate it
into the language of film and then we
got to the day and of course as an actor
all you want to do is all that
preparation and then let go and then
just and and I heard Sally Field
describe it she said you know skittering
along the surface but all you want to do
is fly and I wanted to fly that day so
bad and I couldn't and I couldn't and I
couldn't and then I had and then Tom
came out too and I said I can't he was
so kind and then he just said it's not
an iconic song it's a howl I loved
singing when I was a kid I sang at
school and then as I started acting in
fact I was in Cameron Mackintosh
production of Oliver when I was about 10
years old I played the fourteenth Oh
chin to the left but I told him this at
the audition but he had no memory no I
hadn't sung for about ten years but that
wonderful thing is I'm sure everyone
here knows with filmmaking is that when
you get apart you get the greatest
professionals in the world to help you
and on this you know that as well as
physical transformations for these guys
I didn't have to go under any of that
but certainly what I had to do was a
what felt like a muscular transformation
in order to be able to have the stamina
to sing these songs take off to take
maybe 20 30 takes at a time and that was
a four five-month period with a guy
called Mark Malin who a lot of it was
funny actually a lot of the vocal
exercises that we did daily would like
something out of The King's Speech they
often weren't weren't sung they were
involved strengthening your tongue
muscle and things at the back of your
tongue muscle in order to be able to
have a sort of marathon like stamina I I
think the lip-synching to playback is
one of the reasons why more people
haven't embraced the movie musical form
you know I mean at its best you forget
it and you go with it at its worst it
simply embarrassing to watch when the
actors are in control the tempo it gives
the power back to the actors to do what
they do best because great acting you
have to be in control of the medium of
time so you know if Eddie needs to take
a moment for an idea or a motion to form
in his eyes before he can sing so it's
like he's thought he's had to thought
before he's singing it actually spent 18
months working on the on the show and
unpacking it finding out all the things
that weren't actually working in the
show it's a fantastic show but a lot of
character and plot plot developments
don't really work their way through so
we went back to the novel to to look at
some of the source material we went
through it in depth we looked at all of
the obviously Victor Hugo the research
but when it came to the day Tom just had
a way of giving a sentence and with the
soliloquy I always thought this is a
tough thing it's right at the beginning
of the piece in a way you never see him
lower you never see a lower point for
the character and structurally normally
you'd get that and somewhere near the
end or on the third act and Tom said to
me guess who I've never really believed
onstage that that convict five minutes
later and screen time or stage time is
the mayor of the town I need to believe
that something is tapped into so
elementally in that song that this power
rises from within that I feel that
anything is possible and right in that
moment it went from being probably the
most daunting song to one of the
greatest opportunities I felt I've ever
had Hugh was so relaxed expressing
himself through song that you never
yearned him to speak and and and that's
actually pivotal if you can find those
actors who are so at home expressing
themselves through song then then then
you don't keep remembering that the
perhaps they could be talking I adore
Russell in Brussels was the I mean just
he was the cast glue he was the one who
kind of came in and we were all a little
overwhelmed and intimidated by what we'd
had to do but also being really nice
about it and really eager and
Russell just came in kind of said right
coming over for dinner
we're gonna talk all this through and we
all just hung out and he got us to all
relax with it and you talked about
relaxing with it well it was a key part
for us to not only be able to be relaxed
with the material but be relaxed with
each other so that way I became hugh
wasn't just comfortable communicating
through song I was comfortable listening
through song and the way we listen to
music is so different than the way we
listened to own to only dialogue I've
done quite a lot of theater in my life
and everyday was like an opening night
and a closing night all at once cuz you
woke up in the morning you look at my
pillow and think when I put my head back
down on you I may never sing bring him
home again and why I wanted to do this
film is at the center of it it faces
head-on
the elephant in the room for all of us
which is the inevitability of our own
decline and death and it and it somehow
manages to say there is a there is a way
of doing it where you can make your
peace with it and you can transcend it
and that way is through love and in that
that line when he says to see to see the
to look on the face of love is to see
the face of God to me that's the center
of a film this is a love story this is
about a woman who who fights to save her
child and will sacrifice her everything
including her body for love this is
about a man who takes care of this child
and will sacrifice everything for love
and the only way to make sense of death
is through love and being loving in that
moment and that's why I wanted to make
the poem